[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique vous le
savez à cinq mois des élections
municipales france 3 bourgogne donne la
parole aux maires des grandes villes de
notre région
après ceux du creusot de nevers et
d'auxerre c'est aujourd'hui françois
rebsamen le maire de dijon qui est
l'invité de dimanche en politique bilan
de son mandat compte des promesses
tenues ou non il réagira aussi à la
vision que les dijonnais ont de leur vie
il nous dira enfin où ils se situent sur
l'échiquier politique et dans un
contexte national encore très flou et
vous qui nous regarde et vous pouvez
bien sûr commenter cette émission avec
le hashtag jean paul bourgogne françois
rebsamen bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté de nous rejoindre en ce dimanche
matin en direct vous propose de
commencer par une question d'actualité
le retour du voile islamique dans
l'actualité suite à la polémique du
conseil régional où le l'élu rn julien
odoul en raison de la présence d'une
femme voilée dans le public a demandé
une interruption de séance et puis
quelle qu'elles sortent ou qu'elle se
dévoile finalement ça revient comme une
arlésienne cette affaire de voile
islamique ça pourrit un petit peu le
débat public aujourd'hui
oui on doit être le seul pays au monde à
avoir une crise de nerfs autour de ce
problème ça peut se régler de plusieurs
manières
pardon ça peut se régler par là par la
loi ça peut se régler normalement
et puis il faut arrêter les provocations
comme celle qu'a fait cet élu du front
national qui lui considère que c'est le
voile islamique dans un lieu public dans
une enceinte public
je vais faire une proposition j'ai
regardé le règlement intérieur de
l'assemblée nationale
j'ai regardé le règlement intérieur du
sénat bien évidemment il n'est pas
question d'interdire à quelqu'un qui
porte à foulard d'être dans la rue avec
son foulard mais dans des lieux un
certain nombre de lieux à l'école par
exemple qui est protégé bien moi je
propose que dans les assemblées
démocratiques
le règlement intérieur de l'assemblée et
du sénat s'applique à savoir que le
public doit avoir une tenue correcte
ça veut dire pas de short etc le public
doit être assis en silence est découvert
et donc quand on aura adopté ce
règlement intérieur au conseil régional
de bourgogne
eh bien c'était là ça veut dire pas de
voile pas de kippa veut pas de toi qui
conduis
olivier une religieux etc donc on
protège ainsi les assemblées
démocratiques
et puis il faut qu'on arrête parce que
la république est suffisamment forte et
là elle n'a rien à craindre de l'islam
de france je le dis clairement on a vu
quand même que ça a divisé la majorité
présidentielle est ce que vous êtes
plutôt d'accord avec le ministre jean
michel blanquer air qui dit que le voile
n'est pas souhaitable dans notre société
cessons ces son analyse c'est pas la
mienne c'est pas la mienne je veux dire
il est sur l'espace public c'est autre
chose
la société elle n'est pas laïque la
société elle est ouverte à tous la
république est laïque c'est la
république est laïque c'est le service
public qui sont laïques une certaine
vision de la femme
ou comment il énonce une certaine vision
de l'art mal finalement mais il est
réélu famille ce qui serait une femme
qui porte un foulard sur l'espace public
et bien il est libre de le porter la
burqa est interdite
donc les choses sont claires on a le
droit d'avoir un foulard sur la tête de
l'espace public et ces femmes souvent
qui accompagnent les enfants dans les
sorties scolaires etc
eh bien ce sont les seuls à le faire et
donc on a besoin de ces femmes on a
besoin qu'elles s'intègrent dans notre
société on a besoin qu'elles soient à
nos côtés et elles le sont alors même si
la polémique est partie de dijon on va
revenir à dijon puisqu'on vous invite
évidemment avant les élections
municipales de mars prochain vous allez
nous parler de votre bilan mais d'abord
le bilan par les dijonnais eux mêmes
propos recueillis par maeva adamois et
dalila iberraken ben j'aime dans cette
ville
je trouve ça assez plaisant pour vivre
il ya plein de choses et a mis à notre
disposition que ce temps pour le sport
et caetera et moi je trouve ça bien et
pour avoir souvent d'être allé à paris
je ressens pas quand en revenant à dijon
je ressens pas vraiment quand j'ai pas
l'impression d'arriver dans la campagne
franchement on est quand même assez
privilégiés comme je suis maman de trois
enfants
j'aimerais qu'il y ait plus de choix
plus d'activités pour des enfants ou les
petits qu'ils ont 3 4 ans sachant que
sur dijon n'y a pas grand chose à faire
alors chaud sur le plan culturel et à
pas mal de choses à dijon n'est assez
chanceux parce que même au niveau de la
musique on a la chance d'avoir un zénith
et nos salles où il ya beaucoup
d'artistes modernes qui passe et c'est
agréable pour les jeunes et aussi par
exemple avec la création du festival à
dijon ça ramène du monde est ce que des
fois le dimanche à dijon faudrait qu'il
ya un peu plus quand même de l'activité
fonds j'ai beaucoup apprécié le
changement de la ville pendant ces
dernières mandatures
simplement j'ai un tout petit reproche à
faire c'est l'invasion des vélos voilà
les vélos sont passés
comme on dit on s'entend pas avec le
tram les vélos sont pas assez
disciplinés et ils n'ont pas toujours là
le respect des piétons
voilà c'est tout ce que tu ceci non
autrement que m'assurer de sarens s'il
se représente je pense qu'ils
représentent ça continue voilà alors
dijon finalement si c'est une ville
moyenne qui se développe qui s'embellit
etc
c'est un peu le regard qu'ont les
dijonnais que qu'on a interrogés mais ça
reste une ville moyenne c'est à dire
qu'à un moment donné dans les activités
dans les transports dans les activités
pour les jeunes pour les enfants mais on
plafonne aussi un petit peu non pas
d'accord bien sûr j'aime bien cette
vision que des dijonnais donnent de leur
ville parce qu'on sur un micro trottoir
comme ça c'est une vision un peu
particulière bien sûr ce quelques
clients sont pas les dijonnaises
normande et déjeuner et donc ces
dijonnais il s'exprime comme il l'entend
de bien d'ailleurs plutôt bien
dijon c'est une moyenne grandes villes
voilà c'est la quinzième villes de
france
c'est la quinzième villes de france 3
tout est dit sa 15e ville de france
c'est pas la dernière ville de francs
auxquels des choses qu'on peut faire
quand on est maire qu'il ya des choses
qui sont inabordables bien sûr mais ce
qu'on a fait c'est assez exceptionnel
pour une ville de cette qualité c'est
pour ça de cette taille c'est pour ça
qu'elle reçoit tous les labels et tous
les prix qu'elle a reçu cette ville et
donc on a un système de transport commun
qui est je crois un des plus performants
d'europe rapport à la population
bien évidemment on a je crois ici au
niveau culturel tout ce qu'il faut pour
être heureux quand j'ai entendu des
jeunes souhaitant cui pipi a pas que les
jeunes et à l'opéra italien la porte
mais il y en a pour tous les goûts
un opéra dans une moyenne grandes villes
ne viennent pas partout et donc ça c'est
à savoir il ya un opéra il ya une salle
de deux concerts il ya du sport et puis
à la dame qui disait les enfants il n'y
a pas grand chose je veux dire que dijon
est la seule ville de france à ouvrir
son temps scolaire de 7 heures à 19
heures le temps périscolaire et on
regarde les enfants de 7 heures à 19
heures ben vous êtes resté à la semaine
de quatre jours et demi ces craintes de
hausse alors que beaucoup du chasseron
parce qu'elle a toujours je pense je
pense aux enfants des milieux modestes
voilà parce que je suis de gauche est
assez simple alors est-ce que de gauche
c'est aussi mettre les vélos sur les
trottoirs vous entendu le monsieur ça
vous a fait un petit peu sourire c'est
vrai qu'il ya la particularité d'avoir à
on s'est pas le cas dans toutes les
villes de france d'avoir une partie de
la pide piste cyclable qui est sur le
trottoir
est ce que c'est vraiment pratique il ya
20 ans dijon avait le clou rouillé
c'est-à-dire y avait pas un un maître de
piste cyclabe y en a aujourd'hui 64 km
donc c'est beaucoup et on va encore
continuer il faut dire les choses comme
ça c'est sûr c'est l'histoire ça va
venir
et puis quand on chausse et comment
trottoirs chaussée
ça dépend ça dépend des endroits où on
les fait passer ce qu'il faut c'est
avoir une sécurisation c'est vrai ce que
disait monsieur pour pour les piétons et
puis rappeler les règles au au cyclisme
bien sûr dans dans l'espace protégé on
marche on est à la vitesse du pas voilà
alors avec cette question qui est arrivé
dans l'actualité il ya quelques quelques
jours celle arrivée des fameuses
trottinette en libre service électrique
qui pose déjà un certain nombre de
problèmes à paris et à lyon par exemple
est ce que vous avez prévu vous aussi
comme gérard collomb à lyon par exemple
de réglementer en dix ans mais ça doit
pas rouler sur les trottoirs
bien sûr mais on attend la loi il va y
avoir une loi qui va donner le cadre le
règlement et donc on appliquera
j'attends avec impatience cela parce que
il faut que vous sachiez faut que tout
le monde sache qui se vend aujourd'hui à
peu près 300 mille trois cent mille
trottinettes électriques par an et que
les prévisions économiques c'est un
million de devenir culte vendu de
trottiner nous dit on pourra pas faire
sans mais on en aura partout d'ici trois
quatre cinq ans
il faut s'y préparer il faut le savoir
et donc il faut que la loi nous dise ce
qu'il faut faire comment encadrer et
comment limiter la pollution que ça peut
entraîner en attendant la loi ça vous
inquiète depuis un mois là vous avez
religion ça va encore à peu près mais on
est on est vigilant bien évidemment et
puis je les incite comme pour les vélos
comme pour les voitures aller doucement
le plus doucement possible alors nous
risquons brive et ils sont à 25
kg mais c'est vrai comme d'habitude à l'
approche des élections municipales c'est
la sécurité qui fait la une de
l'actualité alors il se trouve que c'est
particulièrement le cas à dijon et dans
son agglomération où les faits de
violence urbaine se multiplient
qu'est ce que vous vous pouvez faire sur
cette question interpellé le ministre de
l'intérieur
et dire au ministre de l'intérieur que
j'ai eu au téléphone il ya maintenant
une semaine que ce n'est pas tolérable
de laisser des quartiers entiers
je pense à un quartier de chenôve où la
police est agressée en permanence
attaquer et des véhicules brûlés ce
n'est pas tolérable et la sécurité des
personnes et des biens elles relèvent de
l'état et pas donné pas de quelqu'un
d'autre elle relève de l'état qu'est-ce
qui vous répondra policiers travail
formidable pendant un an pour les
manifestations des gilets jaunes tous
les samedis c'est ça a été un
investissement merci à eux
policiers gendarmes ils ont fait un
travail vidéo où ils étaient mobilisés
sur autre chose mais du coup du coup ils
ont délaissé les quartiers est et vu
qu'il ya pas que les embauches de
policiers prévus eh bien ils sont en
sous nombre qu'est-ce qui les niches à
mons où nombre dans cette ville qu'est
ce qui est aujourd'hui le ministre
castaner ce qu'il allait regarder le
texte mort m'a dit oui je mesure ce que
c'est je vais faire tout le nécessaire
j'ai demandé à ce qu'il y ait une crs
qui soit là pour sécuriser pendant un
mois les quartiers ramener la paix dans
les quartiers c'est pas possible qu'on
laisse les choses à évaluer le manque
d'effectifs à combien dans
l'agglomération est ce que vous arrivez
à évaluer il faudrait il faudrait qu'il
y ait 40 à 50 policiers supplémentaires
pour pour sous les soulager les soulager
mais ils font tout ce qu'ils peuvent
regarder ce qui s'est passé dernièrement
à chenôve là ils ont été agressés mais
pas par des voyous faut quelque chose
comme ça il combat pas par des sauvages
compris désigner le maire de chenôve
aujourd'hui alors que alors qu'on a
plutôt tendance à aimer les maires on
voit de plus en plus d'agressions de mer
on pense à celui de montbrison dans la
loire
kiki qui se maintenant se développe
finalement moi j'ai jacques roth
j'apporte tout mon soutien
bien évidemment à thierry falconnet
j'allais encore appelé hier après midi
c'est intolérable c'est intolérable de
s'en prendre à la police un tollé à 200
points gendarmerie c'est intolérable de
s'en prendre à un élu de la république
et donc il faut absolument qu'il soit
protégé
est-ce que vous parliez tout à l'heure
d'homme de gauche est-ce que vous
l'homme de gauche vous vous dites pas
que certains élus ont péché par moments
par naïveté ou pensant que en réglant
les problèmes sociaux des quartiers on
allait régler la question de la
délinquance c'était un moment donné
l'aveu
d'un certain lionel jospin quand il a
quitté matignon cc ya longtemps mais moi
j'étais un de ceux de gauche qui passait
pour quelqu'un de sécuritaire parce que
j'ai toujours considéré que ce sont les
milieux modestes
ce sont les gens les gens qui vivent
dans les quartiers qui sont les premiers
frappés par la sécurité et donc c'est
d'abord à eux qu'on doit penser et moi
je pense à eux et c'est pour cela que
j'ai voulu mettre des caméras de vidéo
surveillance au moment où on disait ah
bah non il faut pour m j'en ai mis tant
mieux et on va continuer à développer ce
système on a un système centralisé mais
la sécurité je le répète pour que tout
le monde comprenne bien la sécurité des
personnes et des biens ne relève pas des
mères elles relèvent de l'état
voilà du coup ça vous laisse un peu
désarmée mais je ça nous laisse
désormais je suis pas le seul j'ai écrit
avec neuf maires de grandes villes de
toulouse de l'île de nantes au ministre
de l'intérieur pour lui dire il faut
lutter contre la drogue qui pénètre dans
les quartiers et il faut rétablir la
paix civile dans ces quartiers j'attends
des réponses
j'attendais j'attends un soutien des
élus de la majorité et tout le monde
doit se mobiliser
alors c'est un vrai sujet ça entraîne
quand même une difficulté pour les
habitants de chenôve depuis quelques
jours on va voir une photo de du tramway
dijonnais
ce tramway n'arrive plus jusqu à chenôve
le soir est-ce que vous avez une info à
nous donner est ce que ça va rentrer
dans l'ordre comme c'est prévu à partir
de demain à ça rentrera dans l'ordre
à condition qu'il n'y ait plus
d'agressions sur les chauffeurs de tra
moi je suis d'une totale solidarité avec
eux ils peuvent pas ils peuvent pas se
laisser attaquer les trams sont les
caillassant face est insupportable
j'allais dire ce que dit tout le monde
mais que fait la police
c'est une mesure de sécurité mais du
coup ça impacte évidemment les habitants
du quartier qui comme vous le disiez
sont pâles sont parfois des gens
modestes ne tuons pas d'autre moyen de
transport etc
il faut pas que ça perdure en fait non
on a mis un système de substitution pour
le moment avec des bus de substitution
mais c'est pas satisfaisant c'est pas
satisfaisant très bien fonctionné
pendant cinq ans il n'y a pas de raison
que cela ne continue pas donc moi
j'appelle les forces de l'ordre
j'appelle le miz l'intérieur à rétablir
l'ordre civil sur ce quartier alors on
va passer à un autre sujet d'actualité
qui quittent dit quelque chose aussi de
votre bilan je vais vous montrer cette
photo voilà est ce que vous pouvez me
dit
qu'est ce que c'est et où c'est s'il
vous plaît il ya écoutez je regarde
cette photo et je vois c'est une image
de synthèse précisément d'ailleurs même
si c'est fini des normes des magnifiques
bâtiments qui pouvait faire penser à je
ne sais pas par exemple on peut être en
partie mais pas seulement c'est l'ancien
hôtel dieu de lyon et fière a été ouvert
au public le la fameuse cité de la
gastronomie de lyon ça c'est un peu tiré
la bourre si j'ose dire c'était un petit
peu la guéguerre entre dijon et lyon
pendant pendant le temps du choix de la
cité de la gastronomie finalement dit le
lion c'est un petit peu raccrocher aux
branches et l'autre dans le choix qui a
été fait cependant c'est à dijon qu'on
attend toujours l'ouverture de la cité
de la gastronomie est ce que ça fait
partie des regrets de votre mandat qui
fait partie des regrets de ce mandat
c'est ce nombre de recours qui ont
retardé la sortie la réalisation de la
cité internationale la gastronomie et du
vin
s'il n'y avait pas eu tous ses recours
eh bien nous serions en avançant je
voudrais dire quand même que le projet
lyonnais est un projet petit par la
taille le projet dijonnais plus
ambitieux beaucoup plus ambitieux
beaucoup plus ambitieux faire plaisir
gérard collomb le réseau mais le seul le
réseau des villes qui ont été retenus
comme cité internationale la gastronomie
y en a quatre et à dijon il ya lyon il
ya tureia réagissent ces quatre villes
et bien les projets sont différents
le nôtre est un grand projet reconnue
comme telle mais simplement il a été
pénalisé par les recours d'un élu de
l'opposition qui a bloqué le
développement économique et la création
de ce pôle culturel magnifique qu'on
attend de cet hôtel qui va s'installer
sur ce qui est demain ce qui sera demain
la guerre des cités de la gastronomie
est ce que c'est pas le signe des
difficultés pour dijon d'exister entre
paris et lyon d'avoir sa place qu'on
disait tout à l'heure à cette taille un
petit peu hybride finalement une
métropole mais une petite métropole oui
une petite métropole il ya des grandes
métropoles via des petites métropole
reste compétitif et attractif mais ça ne
l'est pas son économie on a une filière
de la santé qui est exceptionnel qui
créent de l'emploi pas tous les jours
avec des entreprises exceptionnelles
eurent beau crochet kt proteor voilà on
est en avance on a un chu qui rayonne
c'est un combat d'exhibition quand même
si c'est un combat de tous les jours
être mère et vouloir faire bouger sa
ville l'emmenait au plus haut parce
qu'il faut l'emmener au plus haut elle
est toujours dans les trois quatre cinq
premières villes de france sur tous les
classements la ville de dijon
donc c'est pas une petite ville mais moi
j'avais résonné dès le début nous sommes
les seuls à l'intérieur d'un triangle
qui fait paris strasbourg et lyon et
nous sommes c c'est ça notre qualité
nous sommes attractifs nous sommes
ouverts nous avons une université de 34
mille étudiants vous savez je disais
oxford cambridge qui sont des grandes
universités
ils ont trente mille étudiants et c'est
une ville de 150 mille habitants à faire
plaisir aux universitaires de dijon qui
sont comparés à oxford et quand nous les
chars le maire aujourd'hui ils le savent
ils le savent ils le méritent ils le
méritent votre plus grand succès est ce
que vous diriez que c'est cette photo
qu'on va voir celle du musée des
beaux-arts de dijon plus de deux cent
mille visiteurs en quelques mois
seulement c'est votre grande réussite de
ce mandat
oui c'est au pas que de ce mandat deux
des trois mandats en réalité ce qui
donne les travaux ont duré long de la
mesure du temps nous avons métamorphosé
redynamiser transformer le musée des
beaux-arts pour en faire un produit
touristique exceptionnelle d'ailleurs il
suffit de voir la saison touristique
qu'il ya eu cette année on parle
l'attractivité s'ajoute un message ou
énormément les restaurants fleuristes
les hôtels se développe tous les jours
on annonce la création d'un nouvel hôtel
d'un nouveau restaurant
dijon est devenue une ville très
touristique trois millions et demi de
visiteurs
vous êtes même aller faire de la pub
dans le métro parisien mais partout pour
l'amuser partout mais moi je suis un
ambassadeur de ma vie j'aime ma vie
alors on va écouter les autres qui
aiment leur ville évidemment ce sont les
dijonnais je vous propose d'entendre
encore un peu ce qu'ils ont à vous dis à
françois rebsamen
je dis bravo pour le tram
et pour les bus aussi c'est vraiment
très très agréable de se déplacer dans
sa ville il ya juste un petit bémol
c'est que il a bétonné il a fait des
immeubles pas loin d'une d'une vieille
église quand que ces rues baudin et mais
bon je trouve que les immeubles sont un
peu trop près de l'église ce que j'ai à
lui dire c'est que il a réclamé à cor et
à cri de l'aide de la police pour les
banlieues est la question que je me pose
c'est comment ça se fait qu'il n'est pas
venu les chercher samedi alors qu'ils
étaient en embuscade dans la rue de la
préfecture pour taper sur les gilet
jaune
voilà nous vivons dans un type 3 on est
cinq personnes ça fait trois ans qu'on
demande eu un logement et toujours
aucune réponse
donc c'est un peu bouché par rapport à
ça et on aimerait que il est plus de
logements pour les familles nombreuses
bah peut-être encore grossir les choses
par exemple plus de bus le tram le plus
tard ou encore d'autres festivals ou
d'autres activités autres que la musique
transports logement sécurité le maire
est apportée d'engueulades on le voit la
wii c'est la diversité de la vie c'est
bien voyez il ya tout à la fois des
choses assez contradictoires des gens
qui ont des maisons aujourd'hui sont des
gens plutôt aisée y vendent leur maison
un des promoteurs
voilà au moment de moments d'une
succession et donc qui vendent leur
maison ils construisent
il laisse construire sur la maison le
plus que nous avons adoptée réglemente
la construction mais ne peut pas
empêcher les constructions
je vous ne le souhaitez pas il ya besoin
de logements sur l'agglomération
dijonnaise adam vient de le montrer il
ya besoin de logements sur
l'agglomération et la ville se développe
je rappelle que la ville se développe
raisonnablement elle est passée de 148
mille habitants à 150 8000 habitants
c'est la seule ville du grand est qui
gagnent des habitants mais pourquoi elle
gagne des habitants parce qu'on
construit des logements
il faut construire des riffauds quand
même temps car les espaces verts y en a
beaucoup il ya 46 mille arbres à dijon
donc voilà une belle photo d'ailleurs
avec des arbres place darcy avant il y
avait que deux des voitures et il
beaucoup de goudron alors pour répondre
aux sollicitations de tous ces dijonnais
françois rebsamen il faut éventuellement
être candidat à sa propre succession à
la mairie de dijon on va parler de la
mairie de dijon parce que c'est le maire
invite même cinéma oublie que vous êtes
président de la métropole
est ce que vous avez envie d'y retourner
en mars 2020 vous n'avez pas encore
donner votre réponse parce que certains
sont dans c'est normal ils sont pas
connus ils sont dans comment dire sont
déjà dans l'élection
mais moi je connais ma vie je connais
les habitants ils sont pas du tout dans
l'élection
ça viendra le temps viendra et je ferai
connaître ma décision le moment venu
pour le moment j'ai encore à préparer le
budget de la ville de dijon le budget
est de la métropole est encore beaucoup
de choses à faire
donc je suis dans l'action brrr je suis
encore dans l'action je pense approche
comme un j'annoncerai ma décision après
les fêtes de noël voilà je pense qu'il
faut laisser passer cette période de
fêtes
ils me demandent rassemblement de tout
le monde les voeux la période des voeux
après après je prendrai m ça veut dire
que vous n'avez pas encore décidé où que
vous avez décidez vous savez ce que vous
voulez je sais ce que vous savez ce que
vous parce que lors de la précédente
campagne vous disiez c'est mon dernier
mandat
ça c'est des choses qu'on a déjà entendu
vous avez fait trois mandats certains
pourraient dire c'est long oui c'est
vrai c'est donc vous voyez c'est ça a
été mais en même temps ça relativise le
temps c'est le temps de la rénovation du
musée mais j'ai encore plein de choses à
faire le problème c'est ça si si j'avais
quand on a plus d'idées il ya vu ça vous
démange et encore des trucs à faire et
j'aime tellement cette ville je pense
que je peux encore lui donnez vous voyez
je jeu mûri dans ce sens ma réflexion je
peux encore lui apporter des
propositions
j'aimerais qu'il y ait un grand centre
d'art contemporain pour compléter le
musée des beaux-arts vous pourriez
apporter à la ville revient mais
j'aimerais bien voir terminer la cité
internationale
ensuite vous passerai la main et encore
je sens que j'ai encore des choses à
faire à la tête de la chasse à la tête
de la métropole ou à la tête des deux
cantons veut construire le vivre comme
ça a scellé le 2 2 faut tenir de
soutenir les deux il faudra quelques
mois pour raisons de santé j'ai cette
envie oui vous avez retrouvé
on est très heureux pour vous pleine
forme mais il ya quelques mois pour
raisons de santé vous aviez laissé les
de la ville nathalie koenders on va voir
qui est votre adjointe nathalie koenders
vous diriez qu'elle a démérité au point
que vous ayez envie finalement d'y
retourner alors qu'à un moment donné on
s'est dit tiens françois rebsamen va lui
passer la main on l'a senti un quand
vous êtes revenu que y'avait j'avais une
épreuve
oui il ya des millions de personnes qui
sont passées par là j'ai eu un concert
je les dis j'ai fait savoir quand
j'étais guéri je suis guéri et j'ai
félicité
nathalie koenders pour le formidable
travail qu'elle a fait pendant les six
mois où j'étais non pas absent de la
ville mais je voulais et je voulais pas
montrer cette image de quelqu'un de la
maladie et donc mais j'ai tenu au
courant les gens j'étais dans la
transparence
ll est tout à fait compétente tout à
fait capable et sûrement j'espère un
jour peut-être demain il sera maire mais
on ne sait pas quand quoi mais non je
n'ai peut-être à vous montrer une autre
photo c'est celle de sylvain comparot
ancien socialiste est ce qu'il a été il
est aujourd'hui investi notamment par la
république en marche la créer une
association qui s'appelle pour dijon il
est investi également par lui dit pour
être tête de liste aux municipales
est ce qu'il a été déçu vous ne lui est
pas n'ayez pas laisser une petite place
au point qu'il se présente aujourd'hui
face à vous finalement même s'il n'est
pas encore officiellement candidat
non mais j'ai pas donner ou pas donner
de place
sylvain comparot je les ai côtoyés
souvent puisqu'il était directeur de
cabinet du président de l'université
donc je les ai vus il défend des
l'université de dijon bourgogne ou aussi
mais il a été sociale puis il a été
cherché à lille j'ai même été je me
mettais le défendre dans une une
campagne que tu était candidat à
châtillon-sur-seine
entre nous il vous a fait une offre de
services avec son association pour dijon
est-ce qu'il est venu vous voir en vous
disant est ce que finalement vous
n'aurez pas une petite place pour moi
dans quelques semaines on charles rozoy
est venu me voir mais
il n'est pas venu me voir du coup
peut-être parce que je suis pas
officiellement candidat silva oui c'est
peut-être pour ça mais il aurait pu
anticiper peut-être sylvain comparot
c'est un peu une nouvelle génération est
ce que c'est ça peut éventuellement dire
quelque chose du mandat de trop vous
pourriez faire m'a vu l'équipe le
nouveau monde l'a vu l'équipe que j'ai
avec moi je pense que la nouvelle
génération elle est dans l'équipe
municipale aujourd'hui est-ce que la
république en marche
en mettant en avant quelques uns
finalement pas connu alors qu'il ya des
gens à la république en marche qui sont
très connus est ce que enfin qui sont
plus connus en tous les cas que sylvain
comparot ce n'est pas lui faire injure
est-ce que c'est pas une façon de vous
laisser un petit peu le champ libre à
vous avec éventuellement des des
contreparties plus tard je vais vous
montrer une autre photo aller qui
donnera lundi ce c'est celle de françois
patriat alors rions peu oui ça c'est
emmanuel macron alors c'est aussi
intéressant dans l'art les illustres
ensemble avec emmanuel oui c'est vrai et
françois patriat il était ministre aussi
oui mais vous l'avez côtoyé sur les
mêmes bancs vous l'avez côtoyé son image
du sénat sur les ordinateurs de mango
voilà du parti socialiste est ce que il
n'est pas à la manoeuvre dans cette
affaire finalement en demandant à
sylvain comparot d'y aller est-ce qu'il
vous demande quelque chose pour les
prochaines sénatoriales par exemple qui
a encore beaucoup d'élus socialistes
doivent vous êtes qui voit les
sénatoriales je ne je ne sollicite
personnes je ne demande rien je vais mon
chemin
vous vivez mon chemin sans patrie vous
sollicite messieurs jeu j'aime bien
françois patriat
c'est une histoire tellement ancienne la
nôtre on se connaît tellement voilà mais
il a pris un chemin qui n'est pas le
mien
il avait un chemin qui n'est pas le mien
vous vous êtes encore socialiste lui
n'est plus à moi je suis membre du parti
socialiste
ça veut dire encore quelque chose pour
les jeunes qui nous regardent être
socialiste aujourd'hui en 2019 en 2020
dans une ville ça veut dire quelque
chose
ce que nous faisons dans la ville notre
façon consciente agile l'économie le
social l'écologie le sport et la culture
c'est différent quand c'est la gauche
pas uniquement socialiste et puis là les
municipal c'est pas une question
d'étiquette c'est une question d'homme
je vais vous dire la vérité tout le
monde le pense
aujourd'hui il y aura quand même selon
les affiches ou pas non non j'ai pas
besoin de logo d'ailleurs beaucoup de
maires socialistes des gagnants il y
aura pas que les socialistes je crois
pas que des socialistes sur le modem
éventuellement ma liste la liste que
vous soutiendrez en tous les cas lionel
lemaux démentira pas avec l'arrêt modem
est un allié et je souhaite qu'il reste
avec nous on a fait tellement de choses
ensemble
on a quelques secondes avant de se
quitter on vous a demandé de vous prêter
un petit exercice il ya quelques jours
celui du cmfi alors vous n'avez pas
alors le pape fait des selphy emmanuel
macron flessel fille mais le maire de
dijon ne fait pas de celle fille bon
mais je montre quand même la photo parce
que je suis dans mon jour de bonté
alors cette image c'est la place de la
sainte chapelle
qu'est ce qu'elle représente la
piétonnisation l'art urbain qui arrive
le musée des beaux-arts et l'écologie
l'écologie c'est pas uniquement des
arbres en ville
je dis à tous ceux qui pensent ya passé
très brute de la liberté que de la
liberté le sous sol est truffé de réseau
vous voyez donc on peut pas mettre des
arbres parfumé par contre quand on peut
remettre en en mai mais c'est tellement
beau ce musée rénové cette place ouverte
aux piétons et ça sera l'image de la fin
de cette émission merci françois
rebsamen d'avoir accepté cette
invitation ce dimanche matin merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis aujourd'hui
dans un instant le point sur l'actualité
régionale
c'est avec emmanuel pinsonneault suivi
de la partie nationale de dimanche en
politique francis letellier reçoit le
député européen écologiste yannick jadot
mon dimanche
[Musique]